Let's start with a warm
up ratio problem.
Then we can tackle some harder
word problems. So I have the
ratio 13/6 is equal to 5/x.
I don't like having this x in
the denominator, so let's
multiply both sides of
this equation by x.
So if I multiply both sides by
x, what's going to happen?
On the right hand side, this
x cancels out with that x.
And then the left hand side
going to become 13 over 6x is
equal to-- you're just going
to have a 5 there.
And then to solve for x, you
just multiply both sides by
the inverse of 13/6.
6/13.
These, obviously, cancel out.
That's why I multiplied
it by the inverse.
And you get x is equal to 5
times 6, which is 30/13.
Now one way that you might see
this done-- it's kind of
skipping a step-- is called
cross multiplying.
You look at a ratio like this,
and you immediately say the
numerator on this side times the
denominator on that side
is equal to the numerator
on this side times the
denominator on that side.
Let me write that out.
So you might sometimes see
people immediately go to-- let
me just rewrite the problem
actually-- So that original
problem was 13/6 is
equal to 5/x.
You might sometimes immediately
see someone go to
13 times x is equal
to 5 times 6.
And it might look like magic.
How does that work out?
Why does that make sense?
And really, all they're doing
to get to this point is they
are simultaneously multiplying
both sides of the equation by
both denominators.
Let me show you what I mean.
If I multiply both sides of this
equation by 6 and an x,
what's going to happen?
If I multiply it by 6x times
both sides of this equation--
And where did I get the 6?
From here.
Where did I get the x?
From there.
Both denominators.
What's going to happen?
On this side of the equation,
the 6 is going to cancel out
with this denominator.
And on the right hand side of
the equation, the x is going
to cancel with this
denominator.
So you're going to be left
with 13 times x is
equal to 5 times 6.
So nothing fancy there.
You're just multiplying by the
denominators of both sides of
the equation.
And it looks like you're
cross multiplying.
13x is equal to 5 times 6.
And then from here, of course,
you divide both sides by 13.
You get x is equal to 30/13.
Now that we're all warmed up,
let's tackle some actual word
problems.
So we have the highest
mountain in
Canada is Mount Yukon.
It is 298/67 the size
of then Ben Nevis.
Let's Y for Yukon is equal to
298/67 the size of-- let's say
N for Nevis.
That's what this in
green tells us.
The highest peak in Scotland.
Mount Elbert in Colorado
is the highest peak
in the Rocky Mountains.
Mount Elbert-- so we have this
other information here-- Mount
Elbert is 220/67 the height
of Ben Nevis.
So let's say, E for Elbert.
E is equal to 22/67
times Nevis.
Times the same Ben Nevis,
right there.
And they're telling us more.
And, it is 44/48 the
size of Mont Blanc.
So Elbert is equal to 44/48
the size of Mont Blanc.
Let's write B for Mount Blanc.
They also tell us Mont Blanc
is 4,800 meters high.
Mont Blanc is 4,800.
meters high.
So B is equal to 4,800.
And they ask us, how high
is Mount Yukon?
So we have to figure out Y.
So let's see if we can work
backwards, and figure out all
the variables in between.
So let's start with this
information here.
B is equal to 4,800.
E is equal to 44/48 times B.
So E-- so Elbert-- is equal to
44/48 times Mont Blanc, which
is 4,800 meters.
Now if you divide that by 48--
4,800 divided by 48 is 100.
So Elbert is 44 times
100 meters high.
So it's equal to 4,400 meters.
Fair enough.
Now we can use this
information and
substitute it over here.
We get Elbert, which is 4,400
meters high, is equal to
220/67 times Ben Nevis.
N for Nevis.
To solve for Nevis, we multiply
both sides by the
inverse of this coefficient
right here.
So we multiply both
sides by 67/220.
So times 67/220.
The 67 cancels with that 67.
That 220 cancels
with that 220.
And then you get-- let's see,
if I take 4,400 divided by
220-- 440 divided by 220 is 2.
So this is going to be 20.
So 4,400 divided by
220 is just 20.
So you get Nevis is equal
to-- I'll swap sides.
So Ben Nevis is equal to
67 times 20 meters.
And now that's what?
1,340 meters.
Is that is right?
Well, lets just leave it like
that, because we could--
actually it looks like that's
67-- I'm going to leave Nevis
as 67 times 20 meters.
And substitute it right there.
So Yukon-- I'll just go down
here, because I have more real
estate there-- Yukon is equal
to 298 over 67 times the
height of Nevis.
Nevis is 67 times 20.
So times 67 times 20.
Well I can divide 67 by
67, and I get Yukon is
298 times 20 meters.
So Yukon is equal
to 298 times 20.
And what is that equal to?
That is equal to-- Let's
see that's 2 times 298
is going to be 396.
Oh sorry, it's going
to be 596.
This is almost 300, so it
should be close to 600.
This is 2 less than 300,
so this should
be 4 less than 300.
And then, I have a 0 here.
So it's going to be
5,960 meters.
And we are done.
Let's do one more of these
word problems. All right.
At a large high school, it is
estimated that 2 out of every
3 students have a cell phone.
And 1 in 5 of all students have
a cellphone that is one
year old or less.
All right.
So let's think about it.
Let's say that x is equal to the
total number of students.
This first line, 2 out of 3
students have a cell phone, so
we could say that 2/3
x have cell phone.
That's what that green
statement tells us.
And then that purple statement--
1 in 5 of all
students have a cellphone that
is one year old or less.
So 1/5 x have less than
1/5 year cell phone.
So they want to know, out of
the students who own a cell
phone-- so it's out of this--
that's our denominator.
So let me write that down.
That is our denominator.
So out of the students who
have a cellphone-- that's
right there-- they want to know
what proportion owns a
phone that is more than
one year old.
So how many students have a cell
phone that is more than
one year old?
Well, we could take the total
number that have a cellphone,
which is 2/3 x.
2/3 of all the students
have a cell phone.
We can subtract out all of the
students that have a new
cellphone-- a cell phone that
is less than one year.
Remember they're saying more
than one year here.
So we want to subtract out all
the students with the new
cellphone, minus 1/5x, and you
will then have the proportion
of students who have
this right here.
This is right here.
This is, have greater than
1/5 year cell phone.
They have a phone, but it's
more than 1/5 years old.
This is all of them that
have a cellphone.
We subtract out the new ones.
So this is, essentially, all
of the people who have an
older than one-year
old cell phone.
So to solve this, we just
subtract the fractions.
So this is just going to be,
let's see, 2/3 is the same
thing as 10/15.
That's 2/3 minus 1/5.
The same thing as 3/15 x.
Which is equal to 10
minus 3 is 7/15 x.
Is the total proportion of
students-- that's this
orange-- what proportion owns
a phone that is more
than one year old?
It's 7/15 x.
That's an actual number.
So if you want to know, out of
the students who own a cell
phone-- so out of the students
who own a cell phone, right
there-- 2/3x, what proportion
owns a phone that it is more
than one year old?
This is the number that own a
cellphone that is more than
one year old.
And this whole value is the
proportion out of the students
who have a cell phone.
Lucky for us, the
x's cancel out.
And we are left with this is
equal to 7/15 times the
inverse of the denominator.
You divide by 2/3.
That's the same thing as
multiplying by 3/2.
And what does this equal to?
Divide by 3.
We are left with 7/10.
So of the students who own a
cell phone, 7 out of 10 of the
students who own a cell phone,
own a cell phone that is more
than one year old.
And we are done.